what's up guys
lunch money time friday
friday walsh is trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent polina ivailova marinova
pompliano
aka pimp looking like a traffic cone
what is this outfit or you know you look
like you look like the nfl uh when they
throw the penalty flag they're like
penalty that is a violation of the dress
code i look like a bee
no i've never seen a fluorescent yellow
b speaking of
b b stands for block five block five is
a sponsor of lunch money
you can get eight point six percent
interest in a
interest bearing account with block fi
go and check it out block five dot com
slash lunch money
i've got money in there i'm an investor
in the company in the bank
it is very very compelling there's risk
do your research check it out
block five blockfy.com lunch money okay
to the violation machine what's going on
my god why are you yelling
okay so big tech
[Music]
big tech earnings uh yesterday
you know the silicon valley titans were
being grilled by congress
and their uh second quarter earnings
was the second quarter come on we're um
we're in the third quarter so second
quarter so apple blew expectations out
of the water despite
store closures revenue was up 11
um google for the first time as a public
company parent alphabet reported a
drop in sales which fell two percent
from last year's covet
dragged down ad revenue amazon spent
over 4 billion on safety ppe
extra cleaning and all that stuff still
managed to bring in 5.8 billion
in profits revenue grew 40 annually and
facebook
also reported a good positive change in
revenue earnings and user growth
indicating that downturn in ad spending
during the pandemic
wasn't much of an obstacle so apple
has their store closed but it's still up
11
annually which is the largest ever
increase in the third quarter of the
history of the business
unbelievable amazon still made over 5
billion dollars
even though they spent a bunch of money
on ppe
on bonuses for employees all kinds of
different things
and so what we end up getting is a
situation where
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer in terms of companies
right these are massive tech behemoths
but they're also digitally native and so
it just goes back to the the tailwinds
if you bet on the right thing which is
innovation and technology and
digitization and all this stuff
as those trends got accelerated by the
virus of course they're the
companies that are going to end up doing
well compare apple
with their stores being closed to the
local electronics store
apple's crushing compared to them why it
is a more innovative more
internet enabled type business than the
local electronics store
you can argue whether that's good or bad
but that's just the facts
and the numbers proved it um massive
numbers yesterday you know how yesterday
you said that these companies weren't
monopolies they were just large
companies
somebody in the comments asked okay what
other uh
search tool do you use aside from google
the the whole key is microsoft bing
has millions of users right brave
brave is a is a browser or ducked up go
millions of users again we don't think
of that
but when you look at the actual data it
ends up being
that those other services have a lot of
users now you have to ask
why is google the most popular it's
because it's the best one
it's under it undeniably is the best can
you argue that it's not a monopoly
of course you can because there's
there's plenty of other search engines
you could use
now you may not choose to use them
because they're not better
but being a monopoly means that you it's
winner takes
all not winner take most winner take
most is not equal to monopoly
winner takes all about that but okay
well that's kind of what a monopoly is a
monopoly means one winner
chinese tesla rival expen
motors is in talks to raise around 300
million in funding ahead of the initial
public offering it's planning in the u.s
everybody wants to be electric everybody
nicola is a uh a company that went
public 20 billion
evaluation never had a single company
produced these guys i think
actually a single car produced these
guys
uh trying to raise 300 million dollars
uh supposedly
the qatar investment authority is
involved we'll see what happens there
uh but i don't think that's actually
been confirmed yet that's a rumor
um it's gonna be really interesting to
see
how these um these kind of electric car
wars play out but tesla's winning so far
so it's so interesting because tesla was
kind of alone in the game and now it has
competition
do we think something like x-bang motors
uh can give tesla a good run for its
money
for money for its run run for its money
run for its money you need you need a
couple of things to be successful in
this space
one you need lots of capital creating a
car company is incredibly capital
intensive
two is you need really really deep
levels of innovation
right so that is more of kind of the
high tech type thing and three is you
need
um incredibly repetitive um
sustainable predictable operational
efficiency
so you gotta have lots of money that and
have a lot of innovation and then be
able to execute
right that's essentially what comes down
to in these cars that's pretty easy for
me to sit here saying that in my kitchen
it's incredibly difficult to do those
three things in the kitchen
xping motors they raised uh i think it
was 400 million dollars last november
they then raised 500 million dollars
earlier this month or in july
and they raised it from like big
investors sequoia china
um from kotu a bunch of people right so
they've got a lot of capital
they're not going to gross another 300
million so right there and call it the
last
eight nine months they'll have raised
over a billion dollars in capital
one of the questions is is that enough
or do you need even more
and then two is how innovative are they
and how efficient are they from an
operational standpoint those are
questions that remain to be answered do
you think that some of these electric
car companies even if they can't beat
tesla on
quality they can undercut it on price
no no why no technology naturally is
very deflationary force and you already
see it with tesla tesla started out with
a high price point
uh kind of an exotic sports car type
feel and very scarce and they've moved
down the value chain
in terms of they're producing more cars
at lower prices
and a lot of that has to just do with
operational efficiency and the
deflationary nature of
technology a lot of that is very obvious
when you go and you look in their
facilities
and they have so much robotics and
automation in their production facility
and so tesla is one example that doesn't
mean that ford and gm and all these
other guys
aren't quickly doing the same thing they
absolutely are
but what i think you're going to see is
every single car is going to be electric
at some point in the future
on uh the street i wouldn't be surprised
if governments mandate that at some
point
um but where you get is you get two
competing forces you get the incumbents
that are realizing wait we have to start
moving to electric
and then you get upstarts tesla is
probably the only company that's gone
from upstart to like
now it's becoming an incumbent just in
terms of so business uh
every challenger becomes the man at some
point right if you're successful
so there was a point where bill gates
was um
he was the guy in the garage who was
trying to fight against the man
and he was going to disrupt the world
and do all this stuff now bill gates is
a
you know tens of billions of dollars in
net worth and he's the man
right right and so every innovator
becomes the man if you're successful
enough
and i think that's what we're seeing
with tesla is they have gone from
there's no chance that company can be
successful to now they've got this
well now they're the most valuable car
company in the world and so the question
is just
you know can they fulfill those
expectations um
we'll see are you busy on your uh on
your electronic device on your wrist
there i gotta i get an emergency
notification okay was the emergency
oh just an email oh okay what's going on
with lyft so
everybody's trying to be a one-stop shop
company and everybody's trying to find a
path to profitability
lift is no exception lyft is expanding
its
car rental service which it says will
simplify the rental process for
customers
and help its own path to profitability
this comes at a time when one of the
largest american car rental companies
hertz
filed for bankruptcy what is lyft trying
to do
well just like uber claims to be a
logistics company
right so they basically say look we
started out with
moving people to places but we can move
food to places we can eventually move uh
boxes to places and there's a
transportation logistics company right
so
it's a marketplace to move things to
various places for a customer sometimes
that customer is people who want to move
people sometimes it's food something
whatever
lyft is taking a different approach uh
but similar in structure which is
lyft is saying we are a marketplace but
that marketplace is we will connect you
to
a ride it may be that you have a driver
or that you are the driver right so
whether you rent the car or you just
simply have like a micro rental where
somebody's driving you from point a to
point b in a short period of time
they're still serving as a marketplace
and ultimately what it comes down to is
uh when you're trying to grow a business
that has grown this much so far
you basically start with let's penetrate
one market so uber and lyft did that
then they expand geographically
domestically so they expand throughout
the united states they did that
then they go international which they've
done uh to some level of success and in
other places they failed
but basically once you feel like you've
tapped out your geographic expansion
strategy
you have to look for other lines of
products or services
to continue to grow and so how do you do
that well that's what you're seeing with
uber eats who reads has gone from
non-existent to you know 20 plus percent
of revenue now
lyft is saying wait we've got to now
expand our product offering
um and so this is one thing that they're
trying to do um and they
they are basically partnering with a
german company called sixt
which will supply the cars and the
partnership will keep the cost of owning
and operating a fleet off of lyft's
balance sheet i think that's smart
yeah um i mean classic example of like
these businesses right uber owns no taxi
or owns those cars yet it's the most
valuable transportation company in the
world
airbnb owns no hotels yet it's the most
uh valuable hospitality company in the
world right
lyft is basically saying is there a
world where lyft could actually become
the most valuable car rental service and
actually own no cars have no fleets
you know keep it all off their balance
sheet possibly um and so it's just an
asset light
you know approach to um creating that
marketplace
i like it all right moving on by the way
i was an investor in life we made money
it was cool where are you gonna okay
disclaimer
hong kong hashtag oh my god hong kong's
legislative council election was
supposed to be on september 6th of this
year
but um it's going to be postponed
because according to hong kong law an
election can be postponed
if the city's chief executive's chief
executive
believes it is likely to be obstructed
disrupted
undermined or seriously affected by riot
or open violence or any danger to public
health and safety
that's interesting wow this is something
that i would not have expected to happen
in hong kong but there's many places
around the world that i could expect
this to happen
uh just due to um corruption lack of
democracy
like well i understand why they're
saying what they're saying
but i don't agree that you should be
moving elections uh
in general in a democratic space uh
the other piece of that is obviously uh
in the united states we have a president
who recently
hinted at the idea of potentially moving
the election which he does not have the
power to do
i'm not going to get into the merits of
that uh but what i will
say is one of the core um tenets
of democracy uh in a free world
is free and fair elections um and
part of that in my opinion is the
reliability of the election happening
when it's supposed to happen so but but
here's the thing like now that i think
about it i agree with you but what if
there's
but what if there's riots and violence
in the streets and i'm a little old lady
who wants to go vote but i can't go
through all that violence to get to the
voting booth
like how do i vote i feel like that's
kind of tough
i don't want to go through tear gas to
go vote
so yes but the question is why are there
riots and violence it's because they're
rioting against the people it gets the
power in charge mail win uh we're not
gonna get into all that all right what's
going on with vc
all right so do you guys remember the
college cheating scandal that all these
people were involved in yeah
well i could have gotten to harvard if i
can do i could have uh scandaled my way
in
scandaled that's what they did scandal
joanne um
well here's my issue with this all these
actresses were plastered all over
nobody was talking about the business
dudes and the vcs who were involved in
it because they were
so venture capitalist manuel enriquez
former chairman and ceo of hercules
capital
paid more than 400 000 in the scheme
and he was just sentenced to six months
in prison is it just because he
participated in it or did he do
something else
he um so he he he paid
to boost his daughter's exam scores and
get one
admitted to a university falsely as a
tennis oh i remember this one
uh and he said in a letter to the judge
he was ashamed to acknowledge what he
did was wrong illegal unfair and hurtful
especially
to the many honest college applicants
students and parents so
they him and his wife paid money to have
their daughters
sat exams corrected to boost their
scores and have one of the daughters
admitted to georgetown university
as a purported tennis recruit even
though she did not play competitively
so he pled guilty in october to one
count of conspiracy to commit mail and
wire fraud and honest services
uh mail and wire fraud and one kind of
conspiracy to commit money laundering
that's like a pretty big number money
laundering
money laundering i don't know uh his
wife who has also pleaded guilty was set
into seven months in prison
in march so both the husband and the
wife went to jail or going to jail for
six or seven months to prison
um yeah prison and then uh
prosecutors acknowledged in court
doctors that he was a less active
participant in the mechanism
the mechanics of the fraud and his wife
wow which is pretty
wild uh i how do you correct sat scores
i have no clue but i mean look
is this stuff wrong absolutely did a lot
of people do this over the years
absolutely uh
what's the difference i mean well there
is a difference but uh
there's a slippery slope here of
somebody paying
to uh have their child admitted
under the um tennis program and then not
be a tennis player
or somebody just donating to the
university and their kid who might not
have gotten accepted
otherwise getting accepted another thing
one is a legal
form of doing this the other is an
illegal another difference
another legal form that i i don't
appreciate
is it's kind of like an open secret but
when you're applying to college
there's a little box that says are you a
legacy
student basically has your sister
brother sibling parent grandparent
attended the university of whatever and
you check it
and it's known that you probably have a
higher likelihood of
of getting in if i don't have a problem
with that as well really i do why do you
not have a problem with that
only because uh that is a um
that is a fundraising situation where
you think of it as uh somebody comes to
your university right and they go on and
they leave
uh you want to help your alumni right
and you want them to be successful hold
on you want them to be successful and
kind of do all these things
and so you can also think of it as a
remember colleges are businesses
right and so there's a very similar
business model where
uh i may say to paulina in business hey
it's a hundred dollars
uh a year but if you go and you recruit
more people to come to our you know uh
to
come use our products well you either
get a discount or they get a discount or
whatever and i think of my marketing
dollars
being spread across multiple customers
so i can bring my cost of acquisition
down and my lifetime value goes up i
just
don't like it that because i went i was
born in a different country and i don't
have any legacy people who went to the
university of georgia
like yeah but my point being that like
i'm not saying necessarily that's a
that's an awesome idea or anything that
i'm just saying
i have much less of a problem with the
idea of if you're a brother or mother or
whoever went somewhere
and they and the university wants to
offer that
as a benefit to the alumni that hey your
family can come here
that to me is well that to me is not uh
unethical or illegal you just said it's
a business so why
if i donate money why should i not
expect to get in i just donated some
money
okay again i don't think that that is
unethical or illegal i just don't like
the the idea of donating right it's
basically saying
uh there are parents who are going to
take money and they're going to
spend that money some figured out how to
do it legally
by making a donation and then their kid
gets in versus somebody who says i'm
going to pay to do this
like there's a there's a big thing that
i would say of like
actually you could look at the people
who did the scandal and be like
hey i mean why didn't you just donate to
the school and do it the legal way
i just don't understand the altering of
the sat scores because that has nothing
to do with the individual colleges
there's an s.a.t
board so did you bribe the like how do
you correct us
they might have sent somebody to take
the the test for them there could have
been somebody who
you know we don't know all the details
wait by the way sorry just time out
my i match exactly the words at the
bottom
oh okay that's that's great to know um i
appreciate that fact
uh but no i think the other piece of
this too
is um there's a much bigger trend here
which is like this is all not going to
matter
in 25 years like college is not going to
be a thing
um and it's because of people are always
going to find ways to cheat
well well look by the way i want
everyone to get an education
right and i don't like the idea that
people can just spend
money and then they get like a leg up in
life
but just because we don't like it like
but that's how the world works and so
literally if you have more money you
tend to be healthier you tend to be
safer you tend to you know do all these
kind of things
is that how the world should work
probably not
but is that how the world does work yes
and it's just money is a resource
and if you have resources then you're
able to get access to things education
being one of them but i do think that
technology again deflationary uh trend
is today you can go right now on youtube
and you can type in mit open course
and you will literally be able to sit in
an mit course
and learn exactly what the students in
that class are learning for com
for free cs50 david mayland right at
harvard
and there's multiple universities now
putting out a lot of stuff now yes i
understand that a lot of it is the
introductory type stuff yes i understand
there's a difference between going
in person versus you know sitting at
home and having to be a self-starter
i get all of it my point being that
we're seeing the early signs of online
education
uh there is going to be a complete trend
shift where
it's not going to be worth going to
school in the traditional sense
when you can learn everything online and
i always tell people
why go to a second or third tier school
when you can learn from the
best people in the world online he
learns a lot from youtube
yeah like i i would tell tell me a
industry that you want to be an expert
in
and i will literally go find the top 20
people in that industry
probably have podcasts videos
they've written a bunch of stuff all
that stuff you will learn more doing
that
because in the education system if you
want to learn about let's say
uh history we don't tell you just go
read the five best history books
instead we have a professor who frankly
is probably not the best
you know expert on history but it is
somewhat informed
stand up there and they teach the class
i still remember there was some obscure
thing around
bitcoin or blockchain or something like
that and he literally spent
a day with his headphones on like
reading and
watching things and listening to things
i was like oh my god but then by the end
of the day you're like
yeah i just taught myself interesting
the information's out there just gotta
you just gotta care just gotta wanna be
uh
wanna be smart all right like me ready
at a time but
lunch money live do you wanna tell the
people bang bang tomorrow 12
noon eastern saturday 12 noon eastern me
and my compadre here my partner in crime
we will go live on youtube
so pay attention make sure you subscribe
to the channel we're gonna go live
i don't know for how long maybe we'll
order some dominoes while we do it
and we're just gonna answer questions
whatever you guys want to talk about
saturday 12 noon eastern live but do not
see you there
do not call me pimp do not call me pip
oh
okay all right are you ready for my joke
yeah let's hear it what do you call
a cow i have a lot of cows lately what
do you call a cow in an earthquake
moving no you said that last time
what a milkshake
okay but did the nevermind uh because is
it really milk before it comes out of
the cow
what the the cow creates the milk right
so at what point does it go from the
ingredients that make the milk inside
the cow to actually milk
that's there you go that's the type of
stuff i think about i would go google
that right now and then i would know
how does the cow make milk gotta learn
on the internet read
that's it for lunch monday today well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get her lunch money
right
plane it looks like a penalty flag in
the nfl we'll see you guys tomorrow
at 12 noon eastern bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account go do your own
research
there's risk associated but 8.6 is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends